hey drake how about you quit
[ __ ] up for the rest of this yeah
there's there's like
five guys in the world who could rent
out [ __ ] dodgers he didn't even mean
to let people know though some guy was
just flying over
oh
because it's weird that they just fly
over an empty statement
yeah that night yeah with the camera no
game going on
just with that batty mom mm-hmm and her
son plays at sierra canyon
oh you're calling a few days after he
went on that date with that baddie
he was on nicki minaj's uh instagram
live and he was
texting her like hey the girl you have
on your live with you
she's a singer named bia bad as [ __ ] he
was like oh she's a baddie she's cute
and nicki minaj called him out on her
life saying like go back to your big
booty thing
alone yeah so if you were calling him
out for like hitting on another girl
let drake drink
but i guess it was it wasn't him being
like hey i'll pay whatever
and have a date there i guess he made a
donation to the dodgers so like hey if
you ever
want to have a private dinner here and
he was like all right i'll use it now on
this big titty girl
mm-hmm big everything yeah big
everything she looks she looks
big like yeah she's like very like a
tall curtain you know her son's the
number one basketball player yeah ucla
right he's going to ucla
drake uh he jake's got pictures of him
on his instagram yeah yes they were
saying drake's helping him out with his
financial and i'm like
but she used to date an nba player yeah
she's like helping the kid get somewhere
oh here look at josh what josh poster
your new life is going to cost you your
old one
terrible heavy that's fine can you live
that's basically the movie jen
that's the quote from jim so that's
right on point what does that mean
it's okay is this you common yeah put uh
i put the asterisk and put thick put the
asterisk
that yep that's it perfect so anyways
that kid's a senior
this year isn't it he's going to use his
ucla a baller a baller
isn't he better than braun lebron oh
yeah oh she's better than lebron
but what's interesting she's doing an
nba player and obviously that some
player i've never heard of
she was he was the nba player was
obviously helping the kid get to where
he's you know
with his basketball career that's the
kid right now and then drake shows up
that's the kid yeah it's tall and
they're clearly at dave and buster's so
that's
just [ __ ] chill isaac drake always on
that
hookah they have who got [ __ ] i think
if you agree
if you rent it out you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want if you're drake yeah
god he is [ __ ] leaving
i tried bringing a hookah in the green
room they're like get the [ __ ] out
make sense i'll go back to my drawing
board yeah i mean david lucas love that
go uh
click on that that kid's profile you see
his mom
let's see what you think chen she's
super you oh i don't think she's gonna
find i'll see what chad thinks
i bet he don't post his mom dude it must
be tough does it it must be tough for
that kid
it must be really tough for that kid
because when your mom's a [ __ ]
dime and she but she's not like the guy
that keeps it like
baggy sweaters yeah yeah she's housing
oh it must be
for he got the whole get up yeah it must
be challenging when that's your mom
yeah you know your boys are like dog but
also he ain't mad that drinks
she's probably low-key hype yeah he's
like oh [ __ ] jack's gonna be my stepdad
he's wrong like mom how was that date
it's also awkward though yeah
he's fine he's living kind of though but
it's also your mom so like drake comes
over at like midnight
oh i thought i was gonna see you
tomorrow he's like yeah i'll see you
tomorrow we were just at dave and
buzzers yeah we were i'm here to
see your mom that's what you're doing
she isn't living at home
like a ucla basketball player he's
probably out somewhere else
[Laughter]
old enough to be a mom of a woman 20
year old 20 year old yeah so she's oh
she has to be at least
damn near 38 i bet yeah it's just 40.
40. i don't know how legit that is but
64. i think she's pretty sure she's four
dude that's a grown
[ __ ] woman yeah
that is a woman dog that is
dude she is super pretty so she just
famous because she went out with drake
no so she said she's
and then drake noticed her and was like
hey you're hot as [ __ ] and now they went
on a date at jesus christ they went on a
date
at [ __ ] uh doctor stadium good lord
i'm not gonna lie to you guys my girl
has damn near the same body not gonna
don't mean to flex on you don't mean to
flex no flex
she looks taller but like a pretty
similar body
which is fantastic looks on that
that is what the world knows nice
photoshop very pixelated legs baby
thank you man mini figgies understand
region yeah
meanwhile he's just jacking off that's
usually how it goes
god yeah dawg get it out of my face man
what are you trying to do man yeah it
has to be one more one more
one more [ __ ] that's your mom that has
to be challenging man